each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my pleasure today to welcome my
calf Cano who many of you know those are
you don't but she has a long history of
writing compilers for fail computing
companies are we going over to dinner
last night it was really pretty pretty
amazing the number of supercomputing
companies that came and went over the
history then she went to work for the
deck research lab which became compact
research lab became the HP research labs
now the Intel research labs so you know
if I was at Intel I think I'd be a
little nervous at this point but she's
going to give us a talk today about t
streets this is a new parallel
programming model so I haven't read the
newspaper today if there's any news
about Intel maybe you could tell me so
this is T streams T stands for tagged
and in some of the transitions that I
made I lost some of my team as you can
see here I should also add jeff allow me
to this list i think ok why t streams
why another parallel language where are
we today the idea here is that it's very
hard to see this way try this
um we have cereal languages and we have
explicitly parallel languages the in the
cereal languages the software has to
reason about parallelism and there are
two big problems there one is over
writing and the other one is arbitrary
serialization in explicitly parallel
languages the user has to reason about
parallelism and furthermore they
typically embedded in Syria languages
which have the problem of overriding an
arbitrary serialization and so they're
not appropriate for wide-scale adoption
so I probably don't have to do this with
this audience but on what's the issue
with overriding and serialization
suppose your problem your abstract
problem requires some partial ordering
where oops let's go back where you have
some task a which has to be done before
B and C which can be done in either
order on followed by a task d you have
to write this in some specific arbitrary
serial order so you write a b c and d
and then you want to execute b and c
concurrently and so you have to
determine if this ordering is ok but you
might have had overriding over here so
to figure out whether a of j in c really
refers to a you have to do some analysis
of this stuff and we've been doing
decades of this and this you know
there's a lot of interesting work here
and it's a it's very good work but we'd
like to try something new so the idea
the goal of t streams is to raise the
level of programming just a tiny bit and
the tiny bit is to avoid the overriding
and the arbitrary civilization on the
one hand from the Siri languages but
also avoid the need to reason about
parallelism on for it's both of the
parallel languages on the other so how
do we do this typically or often
parallel languages provide for the user
some kind of knobs and handles
to help control what's going on
underneath in the parallel in the
parallel world and this is quite a
different philosophy we're viewing this
as an interface and an interface design
is quite different from providing knobs
and handles so on the one side of the
interface we'd like the domain expert
the domain expert knows everything there
is to know about finance or genomics but
has no interest in parallelism or tuning
and the tuning expert might be a person
or might be runtime system or static
analysis and they have no interest in
finance except their own maybe but they
are very interested in performance and
so this interface must make explicit
only what the domain expert actually
knows nothing about things they're not
interested in and they don't know but it
has to also contain exactly what the
performance expert needs to know and i
should say explicitly that the domain
expert and the performance expert could
well be the same person just at a
different time during a development so
we start with the the problem the
application problem and we're going to
end up with an actual distribution and
schedule and t streams in the middle is
supposed to separate what's above this
interface and what's below the interface
so above the interface we're concerned
about the serial code semantic
correctness constraints required by the
application on and not any of these
things that are below the interface
which is the architecture the actual
parallelism issues of locality overhead
load balancing distribution and
scheduling all the stuff that we in this
room have probably spent our life time
worrying about him but we don't want we
don't want that stuff to appear above so
the the outline of the talk is basically
starting out with what is these dreams
and how does the domain experts see it
uh that I wasn't supposed to hit that
one okay the second part is given
something in this interface what is the
flexibility provided to the performance
expert to worry about all of these
things and finally something about the
current implementation so I'm starting
out with I have a bunch of examples to
illustrate a few different things here
this one just to show the the basic idea
the idea is that we think you know we
draw a flow charts on the on the board
to explain our application to our
colleagues so we want to start with
something of that nature and then we
need to make it precise so we need to
add exactly enough to make it a precise
specification and a flexible one so this
example is office surveillance so when
you go into a major office building and
you see a bunch of cameras on the on the
desk of the person the reception desk
sort of that kind of thing so one thing
you want to do is background subtraction
see if the camera pointed at some corner
and there is a chair and a plant you
don't care about the chair in the plant
it's going to be in there in every image
you just want to know the people passing
by so you want to subtract out the
background so um the first thing we need
to ask in developing a tea streams
program is what are the operations in
this program in this example we simply
have one operation that's not typical on
the second question is what are the
inputs and outputs of these operations
so we have producer consumer relations
this is a computation and these are data
structures we have the background image
and we have the current image which may
have something other than the background
in it and we want to produce just the
stuff that's in the foreground so so far
this looks a lot like what you might
talk to your neighbor about the next
question is how do you distinguish among
the instances of these there are
instances of the foreground image there
are instances of the background image
we're going to have instances of this
computation one thing to notice is this
is not a streaming application or thread
based application where this thing sits
in some particular place and data
streams through it to get the kind of
performance we're interested in we're
going to have many different instance of
instances of these and they're going to
be placed and scheduled independently
not necessarily independently but
differently so we're trying to say oh
how do we distinguish among these
instances so for each camera we're going
to have a background that doesn't change
per image it's only / camera the image
is from a particular camera and a
particular image and this background
subtraction task is distinguished from
other tasks by again a Cambridge number
and it camera number and an image number
and the foreground image is also
identified by the camera number and the
image number okay so we know how to
distinguish them but we want also the
specific instances so if you have four
cameras you're then each camera number
is going to be a number from one to four
and if you have a stream of images then
each for each camera there are specific
images that that arrive and so this
tells us this triangle here we call it a
tag is going to tell us the exact set
it's not a type it's it's the exact
number of instances and for each camera
number image number pair in here there
is going to be a specific instance of
the background subtraction task so one
way to think about this is it's kind of
like control flow if you think of a a
loop nest you might have I JK loops as
you're going through that you're
computing another each time you go
through it you're computing another
instance of the triple I JK but in
addition in that world you're also
saying do the work now
you know when you compute another triple
you then do the body of the loop what
this is saying is on this is telling us
what the triples are but it's leaving
until later when we're going to execute
them okay I'll go through an example
that focuses a little more on those
afterwards but interrupt me if you have
any any questions okay the next question
is what are the inputs and the outputs
of the program so we're getting a set of
instances that we're going to operate on
we're getting the images themselves and
we're getting the the background for
each camera I haven't put any outputs
here because I'm assuming there's much
more of the program here so this
foreground image is probably going into
some other steps which does more
computation ok so the jargon here is
that we have steps of computation this
is step of computation we have items are
the data we have producer and consumer
relationships we view these arrows and
any arrows that would be going out say
on this side as producer and consumer
relations it's just that the producer of
the consumer in this case is the
environment so the environment is
producing essentially an image so these
are tags of control and we have tagged
components so camera number is its head
component image number is another tag
component and this relationship is
called a prescription relationship so if
there is a camera number image number
say 2 comma 7 here that prescribes the
existence of a background subtraction
task to come seven this just shows you
what the code within a step looks like
so we have the step name it takes in a
tag which is the tag of the instance
there's some serial code which I've
bundled up here and the
function it takes it does a get to get
in an item and the tag of the item it
gets is a function of its own tag so
this background thing is just getting
the camera a number of the of the tag
here the Tet the instance tag here is a
camera number and a an image number it
produces an item does it put oops but
there was one more thing to stay there I
guess not ok so this is an example that
shows a little bit more about how the
tags work because that is the thing
that's a little different in this
language so we have a face detection
algorithm an image comes in and it has a
number of different classifiers the way
this works is instead of doing one
analysis that determines whether or not
there's a face there the community has
the face detection community has divided
it into a number of different
classifiers and the idea is to very
quickly determine if something is not a
face so you look at each window and
determine if it might be a face based on
for instance does it have eyes or
anything that might be an eye and then
for those things that look like they
might have ice it doesn't have a nose
you know etc so I'm just using a
pictorial image here of a pictorial of
an image so in fact we look for a face
not only in the image as a whole but in
windows of the image and so we're
looking in each of those sub windows and
you apply classifier one to each of
these sub windows and four and that'd be
the number of windows comes in from the
outside I mean that's a constant for
some of these windows classifier one
determines that it might be a face in
that window and for each one of these we
have a prescription relation with
classifier to so for each one of these
sub windows we're going to execute
classifier to some of those
classifier too and for those we're going
to say we're going to run classifier
three and if it comes out the other end
of a long trail of these then it's
determined to be a face so and there
might be of course many images that was
just one image on so oops sorry so we're
going to draw this in this way this is a
tag space we're calling t1 t2 t3 etc so
t3 is a subset of t2 is a subset of t1
in this case but i should say at this
point i noticed a paper about c omega
that was called programming with
triangles and rectangles circles kind of
jumped out at me okay let's see oh so
what are the constraints on the on the
parallelism here you can do all the
images in parallel this doesn't say
anything about not doing the images in
parallel and you can do a number of
different windows in parallel the only
constraint is that a specific window has
to pass classifier one before it gets to
execute classifier 2 so this graph here
is telling us only that that order is
required and that's all the thing so if
a textual form of this graph so the
steps were circles items data items or
boxes and the control tags or triangles
and these are the as similar as we could
get them the textual versions of those
so we write one line for each
relationship in the graph this is a
prescription relation which says the t1
prescribes classifier one a consumer
relation that the image is input to
classify one etc and the tags have types
so we define tag t0 which is of type int
and a window type and then each of these
has a tag which is of that type so I
want to show now here's another example
which is a tree-based example so this is
sort of you can think of it as the
divide in a divide-and-conquer algorithm
so dynamically you're going to go
through and create all these different
nodes and associated with each node
there's going to be a tag and a step
that does the computation on the input
at that node and the roots values are
coming in from the environment and we
devise a scheme for labeling these you
start out with the top this is the left
child of the top the right child at the
top this is the left child of the left
child of the top etc just so we can have
some unique tagging and this it would be
a static version of that dynamic tree so
I'd like to introduce the execution
model so that was sort of how you write
a static program in this language and
the execution model you can think of as
instances of of these objects acquiring
attributes these are the runtime
attributes that determine what state
it's in and so we have a step that's
doing divide and this as an instance is
tagged with grr it's prescribed by
divided tag with the tag trr and it
takes in as input the divided item when
this tag is available which is one of
the attributes then this step becomes
prescribed that means it's going to
execute when this item becomes available
then this step has its inputs available
which is another one of the attributes
and when the step is both inputs
available and prescribed and it's
enabled and it can execute when it
executes it might produce a divided item
this is the child the right child of
this node and this is the left child of
that node and in addition it produces
two tags which indicate that the
appropriate steps to to process these
two items are going to execute and when
these items when this step execute then
these items become available they just
have that attribute and when these items
are available of course the process can
start again so that's not necessarily
how a given runtime system will execute
but that's how you think about the
semantics of the program so the the
state of a program is described by the
the forward propagation well the state
is the just the set of objects that have
any attribute and and what their
attributes are but the forward
propagation leads to enabling of the
steps and there's a backward propagation
also that does garbage collection and
the execution frontier is the set of all
instances that have some attribute and
yet are not garbage so it's the things
that we're interested in right now an
termination happens when all the steps
that are prescribed have completed you
can write an invalid term in an invalid
program in which you can't do anything
else and yet there are prescribed steps
that can't run there's certain
properties that I'd like to point out
one is that it's this dynamic single
assignment so you can produce an item
once it's not modified the steps have no
side effects
except to produce items and tags they
are short-lived and that they take their
input they execute they put their output
out and then they die they don't sit
there and take more input and produce
more output and you can freely we
execute them in that the result will be
the same every time and there are no
race conditions so here's an example we
worked with some people at at CMU it
doesn't matter really what this
application is but i'll show you in the
next slide or two and we it has to do
with vision application using stem cell
stem cell growth and they had a paper
describing their serial algorithm and
they use slightly different notation but
basically it looked a lot like this they
had producers and consumers and they
identified data structures and and they
identified computations so we started
out with this it turns out they had some
errors which happens when you try to
make something more precise you find
some errors you know they so not in the
implementation of the algorithm I think
but in the way they described it in
there you know loosely generated figure
in the in the paper I am I'm not sure
that it was actually reflected in the
actual work although and not sure about
that okay so the first question we have
to ask is what are the inputs and the
outputs here so images are coming in and
final states are going out it turns out
that in addition there's a there's a
loop here that concerns the histogram
involves a histogram and so you needed
an initial value of the histogram and so
they
one histogram that's coming in as well
the next question is how do you
distinguish among the instances and it
turned out that by and large they were
all distinguished by a value most of
them or distinguished by a value k which
is what they use for their image number
and the image number is coming in from
outside and there's a prescription
relation with with every step here
that's prescribed by K yeah yeah it says
not all parallel um what happens is as
the as I understand it as the images go
through on their images of something
happening over time so the taking a
picture of the same thing over time and
so they get a prediction about what's
going to happen in the next slide from
what happened in the previous one and it
helps them get better results right
right right exactly so okay so there
were two there were two steps here which
are not prescribed just by K and it
turns out that their distinguished by K
and a particular cell in the image this
is a stem cell in the image and and so
these two need a prescription that is
different from this guy so we have to
know what are the instances of this that
we're going to execute and it's going to
have the same shape that is the same to
tag components and then the question is
well what step here determines what
these instances are in it determines out
that the arbitrator initial part of its
function
to figure out what the what the cells
are and it turns out here that the
arbitrator final determines what these
cells are and that was all we had to ask
him okay once we got this straight we
didn't have to talk about anything else
we were able to put together a TV
program which does exactly this and we
had little stubs that say your code goes
here we couldn't look at their code but
we could execute our code and it did all
the right things but the point is that
there was no mention of parallelism
anywhere in this discussion with him
it's all what is it you know who
produces what who decides what instances
there are parallelism doesn't come into
play and so that's the big message here
were there any questions on that
um T streams I think of as it has its
roots in data flow in tuple spaces and
in streaming so the explicit tuple space
I think is one difference and the other
distinction is not only that these you
know items and and steps are tagged but
we have these texts basis as first class
objects that allow you to say what
you're going to execute without saying
at this stage when you're going to
execute it so it really makes a huge
distinction between what the programmer
knows which is what needs to be executed
and what are the inputs and outputs and
what we care about when we map that to
an actual system absolutely absolutely
right
parallel or something well it's not a
ray like in that it's that you
explicitly are manipulating the text so
sure well can you synthesize them
entirely oh no I'm an action I admit a
bunch of things I just choose the number
of 0 through in or I choose to call red
green and blue doesn't really matter as
long as the final line this and the
square I did have this matchup right
exactly exactly exactly so you do need
to be able to write the types in that
the types come through there the glue
that connects the underlying serial
language to the T streams world but yeah
database administrator one is has only
performance yes that's a great it's a
great analogy I hadn't thought of that
one that makes sense right yeah
dreamer simulate the same thing here
well the condition is embodied in the
step that produces the tag essentially
that's what the condition is but I think
the problem with Linda is your stand
Linda is more that the computations are
long-lived so they they do some
computation they put out some data
they're still sitting there that data
gets used by something else which
produces more data which then the
initial computation we were talking
about takes in now if we're really going
to worry about performance then we'd
like to be able to take those two
instances of the computation and map
them either to parallel computations or
to run on different processors because
we're you know i doing locality
computation locality optimization or
whatever so it's the flexible ability to
place these finer grain computations
that i think is more key you never have
any condition that construction you want
to have basically
right right right there okay so there
are things like insurance or testing the
absence of equals that fundamentally you
decided to avoid do you order to have
that nice property right so there is
this environment so there are no
constraints on the environment ok so
this piece which is the T streams piece
is functional it's deterministic but we
don't have anything to say about what
goes on on the other part of it so the
state of the program is the set of items
in the set of tags that you have an
Indian time absolutely absolutely
absolutely
okay anything else okay I'll show you
these cool pictures so there this is I
love this these stem cells are supposed
to turn into bone and what they're doing
is devising and building a specific
speed piece of skull that they're going
to put in here and they do that by
inkjet printing a sequence of
two-dimensional layers of the stem cells
and a growth factor and the growth
factor with exactly the right
concentrations determines the shape of
the of the bone and what they're trying
to learn in this previous experiment is
how in fact the growth factor impacts
that and so what they're doing is
looking frame after frame and seeing for
a given growth factor comp concentration
what sells split and what cells die and
what cells moving you know all of this
stuff the reason they were one reason
they were particularly interested in T
streams is that it has this flexible
parallel execution model where you could
take the current experiments that they
were doing and do them in soft real time
in with any available resources we could
address their backlog so I call this a
model and I just want to say a few words
about that there are two reasons one is
syntax and one is semantics I'm not that
interested in having big discussions
about the syntax so we have a graphical
form a textual form we have a C++
binding we've looked into pragmas you
know it's really the fundamental aspects
of the language that I care about
furthermore even with respect to
semantics we've made a couple of
different trade-offs for different
instances of this and the trade-offs are
among ease-of-use performance generality
elegance whatever but so there seems to
be a class of languages here and at this
stage you know concerned about exploring
the class
you know I I'm hoping that will zero in
on a small number of these and you know
one or two of these I know or or maybe
we'll keep it as a family so we've done
this part I'd like to talk now about the
flexibility of this next phase once you
have a tea streams program what can you
do with it and the flexibility involves
three things the type of parallelism
that you can exploit the mapping styles
and the target architectures so this is
the type of parallelism we have three
different kinds of computation we have
some instances of foo some instances a
bar and some instances of best and this
is the T stream specification if we
assume each box here represents a
resource and we map them through the
hardware this way then we get instances
of food that can execute in parallel
followed by instances of a bar and
instances of that so it's loop or data
parallelism and if you prefer you can
map them this way you get all the
instances of foo on one resource all the
instances of bar and another one you get
task parallelism if you have a slightly
different application which actually has
some data dependencies and you map them
this way you get a loop or data
parallelism and if you map them this way
to get pipeline parallelism so with the
same specification just with different
mappings the domain expert doesn't have
to worry about what the target is and
the flexibility is there for the
performance expert with respect to
mapping Styles there are basically three
different problems we need to address
one is choosing the grain another is
choosing the distribution among the
resources and the last one is choosing a
schedule within a resource on we can do
them all statically in which case you
can get
data parallelism task parallelism and
pipeline parallelism statically within
the same execution we can do them all
dynamically we can do static rain and
distribution with a dynamic schedule and
we can do static rain and dynamic
distribution and schedule there are
probably other ones but it turns out
that we did one of these at HP we did
one of these at HP the Intel one
currently looks like this and I have a
Georgia Tech student who's looking at
dynamic grain so whatever you want
basically so this is a question of the
target architectures I think it's pretty
clear that you can do a distributed
memory and shared memory just by looking
at the producer consumer relationships
either a synchronization or
communication so I picked two little
more unusual architectures this is a GPU
so let's assume that our previous
implementation we had a bucket of
enabled steps so it might have read
steps and blue steps and green steps at
foo steps and bar steps and anything
that's enabled is in there and a
processor can just go pick one out for
GPU what we'd like to do is have a
distinct bucket for the blue steps and
the red steps etc on and now when the
GPU is ready to run we can look at the
buckets at runtime and decide that maybe
this bucket is a better one to execute
at the moment um take this bucket of
steps which are guaranteed now to all be
enabled and to all be of the same type
and ship them over to the GPU and so I
believe that the languages that are
currently designed for GPU specifically
require that in the static code you get
to some place where you know what static
operation you're doing so I think this
is a little more flexible
um we don't have this we do not have
this implemented if you look at iop you
might have a blue step that you've
compiled for instruction level
parallelism and this one has a tag be
you might have a red step that's
compiled for instruction level
parallelism with the tag IJ without
knowing anything much about these two
you can compile a third step which is a
red blue step which assumes they makes
compilation that the red step and the
blue step are totally independent
although it doesn't know what specific
steps they are and it knows that will
have a tag vij and then at runtime when
there's a red step and a blue step
that's ready to execute it just picks
one out and execute the red blue step
and if there's only a red step ready and
not a blue step then it can execute the
red stuff so we don't have that
implemented either okay so we have to
sum up the flexibility we have loop and
data task and pipeline parallelism we
have dynamic and Static mapping styles
and we have a wide variety of
architectures we're also looking at well
I guess we did some of that oh and your
new processors um what you get here is
flexibility in scheduling so you can use
this whole thing to optimize for the
memory hierarchy so the goal as I said
was to be an interface between the
domain expert in the performance expert
and what we need to show for that is
that the domain expert doesn't need any
knowledge of parallelism that the
performance expert has what they need to
do to optimize for performance so the
last thing is our current implementation
I'm not a C++ programmer so I'm hoping
there aren't too many
so this is just a quick sort example
what you have to look for are the places
where the serial code interacts with
with other codes so where you know with
this code interacts with its environment
so there's the arguments and return
values here it's doing a return here
it's doing it return here are two calls
to itself with arguments and so although
the body of the code doesn't change we
we changed this line to indicate what
the tag is we do gets of the incoming
data then we're going to compute the tag
of the left child put out the item of
the left child here's a separate item
which is just the size of that item and
then we also have to put out a tag of
the left child's indicate we want to
process that data and we do the same
thing for the right and then return so
there's no direct interaction of this
code with its environment with you know
there's no call return thing going on
here yeah so this is the left child and
this is the right child as you know this
whoops yeah that's the left child in the
Rachel exactly
okay the synchronization is that we have
put out into the T streams world on this
data item and we've put out a tag that
says process that data item so back a
number of slides I don't know if I can
go back there in the runtime model where
I said when this tag is available and
when the inputs are available then the
step can execute it's enabled so that's
the synchronization it can't run until
those things are happening
this is a potential problem
Oh
let's say I have
multi megabyte image
and a step that produces the same image
accepting modifies a thousand acer's
some previous dive into my things copy
okay here you're you're not copying the
sub arrangement
yeah okay yeah so you wouldn't really
want yeah that that's a good question um
so we have dynamic single assignment
right now so right now we are assuming
that there's copy and going on what is
the dynamic single assignment property
by you it buys you a couple of
characteristics one of them is no race
conditions and you know exactly which
value your you're looking at but there
are times where you want to do something
in place so we're trying to look at
extending dynamic single assignment to
figure out exactly what the what is it
that will give us those nice properties
you know without throwing out the baby
with the bathwater one of my colleagues
is fun to say and it's looking right now
although this I'm not going to commit to
this like you're required to have a lot
of structure you're required to make
forward progress and anything that makes
forward progress in where you can
identify the nodes in the lattice so in
particular tree is a lettuce and so you
could in place do this with them with
the right mechanism and we're working on
that at the moment so one of the
arguments goes like this i think jim s
last night so how do you know when
you're finished with the old values
before you create the new meds we have
to know right now when we create a value
and we garbage collected we have to know
when all of the users have occurred and
before we do garbage collection and so
by similar mechanism we can know when
all the uses of a particular instance
have occurred before we make a
transition to the next point in the less
so we're looking at generalizing dynamic
single assignment basically to solve
sighs hold fast
write that down how do you spell his
name well what's this blessing okay
great thank you
really oh sure sure so we'd like the
dilemma in that is we would like to
maintain all the simplicity of this and
you know we don't want to get that up
expensive the simplicity because we are
after this wider audience okay so we
look at the calls ok so we convert it to
that then we take the textual
representation of the graph we take this
new version of the steps and we have a
translator which creates some
boilerplate sticks this into the boiler
plate and that's the generated
application and that's the whole deal so
in the future we'd like some other
application some other implementations
maybe you see char on front x-art that
would be so we'd like to have a
mechanism for reuse you know either all
of frameworks kind of the larger
skeletons the sub graphs or graph
structures also reuse of steps and any
combination of the two and as I was just
saying I'd like to generalize the
dynamic single assignment from this is
just some technical history
I guess I'll say this the data
optimization work was work on the
connection machine for locality that
work led to the subspace model which
kind of his the background for for this
in the subspace model we based it on
static single assignment form but after
I finished that work I went back to
readd rest the static single assignment
form because it really wasn't adequate
to the task it was a weak foundation and
the array static single assignment form
is a much better stronger foundation for
these kinds of programs then we did from
based on this week dynamic single
assignment form and at the same time I
was working with some people from
Georgia Tech on the streaming support
for streaming media applications and it
had a notion of tags of time which were
monotonically increasing and I realized
that a combination of these two and this
would give us something much better than
both of them in fact that's what led to
2t streams and this is some NSF work
based on that so that's the whole thing
yeah
I don't think about leadership as
parallel program another big Logan in
the middle I was even parity but how
does how you do you've got how does our
matrix then you have to check can you
meet payroll it's a big change
everything afterwards how you can can
you fit that if your model sure if you
could you can do a reduction is what
you're doing so can you so you you have
to then add up the you add them all here
we will give it back yeah so you can
have loops in these in these graphs and
you can input all instances of an item
into a single step or you can do a
reduction in a more efficient way and
decide whether or not you're going to
make payroll and then you emit a thumbs
up or thumbs down that's no problem
if something is to run not when
I was looking at your quicksort example
and it seems like it's kind of a private
agent server problem and you've got one
tag that describes all the space and
then you're going to cut it into pieces
with the tag you're going to have lots
of taxis describing one thing and sort
of saying with their new position in the
radius you need some way to gather all
that together um okay so what I showed
there was just a divided part of the
divide and conquer and in the divide and
conquer you have a mirror image of that
basically that's doing the contra part
that's putting it all together right and
so you have to have essentially
Jason right that's why is it today that
I want to tag where either you know they
have that bit of the same except for
this one has a zero of it here this has
or the vs. earth medical
so something that relates the two
together
that's what i was seeing in these
presumably simplified specifications
that you see on the screen so i'm not
sure if you yeah catch a person you can
you can compute s yeah what would you
need to do that too sparse and exits
perhaps right after the first count how
many orange one we get a new set of
indices zero often easier than that plus
1 up to the top and you gather those
respectively on your ocular that's a way
you can you can absolutely compute tags
and you if you're wondering where
something goes you will have that word
if you need to match together where
chickens come from that's but in this
case I agree
Reuters deal
so maybe we should talk offline about
this question of where they come from
not sure I understand that yet but that
sounds like my be interesting right
though right can you higher order the
requirements to be an apparent worst of
words
I work at a different system here that
relies essentially specifying relations
between packed to produce a dynamic
specification for the input vector to
these
ok
yeah that does sound interesting right
now we're assuming a forward flow and
the the tags of the input are computable
only from the tag of the step the text
of the output are computable from
anything the input data we've looked at
the possibility of a demand-driven
execution which would require
essentially that the producer also be
computable or we could do it best under
those conditions but I'm not sure that's
what you saw it comes from yeah
applications or we don't have a lot of
applications I've moved around a bit if
you've noticed that's been one problem
we are trying to focus on on image
applications at the moment but this I
mean there are a lot of applications
that would be totally appropriate you
know we have a few fairly small ones and
largely they were designed to to test
out you know particular facilities that
we have we're looking at making this
available to the public fairly soon so
we're going to need applications if you
have any suggestions or volunteers